please stand for the chairman of that
district council
please easy everyone
right well thanks everyone for coming
despite the cold snap
and i can assure you it's as cold up
there up here as it probably is down
there
that's right uh good evening members and
officers of the council members of the
press and public i welcome you to this
meeting of the council
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the building via the emergency
exits
i would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured i
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present does anyone intend to film a
meeting
and i don't see anyone
any filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the press and public from the meeting
with everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used
to make or receive phone calls whilst
meeting is in progress
good
agenda item one apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councillor curry councillor coleman cook
councillor whitehead councillor farence
councillor parsons councillor right
councillor rattican are there any other
apologies
have councillor uh roseki yeah chair uh
council in linda potts
thank you any others
i don't see any others
have we got this great
a general item two minutes of the
previous meetings
i move that the minutes of the council
meeting held on the 24th of february
2022 be approved and signed as a correct
record with the vice chair please second
agree to
the members agree
thank you
agenda item 3 announcements
i have two
announcements first i'd like to uh
congratulate councillor nixie on her
recent election to to the nether court
ward is councillor nixie there
yes thank you very much i'm happy to uh
represent liv screen over here thank you
thank you very much
also uh as a reminder to members please
note that the extraordinary council
meeting scheduled for the next tuesday
will start the slightly earlier than
usual time of 6 pm
so if we all make a note of that
we can all be here
agenda item 4 declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest this evening
and i don't see anyone indicating
a gender item
six
no gender item five
excuse me
petitions
no new petitions have been received in
accordance with council procedure rule
twelve
agenda item six moving on to questions
from the press and public
three questions have been received from
members of the public in accordance with
council procedure rule number thirteen
please note that only the questioner and
respondent are permitted to speak on the
question
could the questioner please only state
the name of the cabinet member to whom
their question is be put and read out
the exact wording of the question that
they are submitted to the council
gender item level 6a question number one
from a member of the public regarding
the identification of brownfield sites
for housing developments
uh hoping to be pleased to welcome mr
court to the meeting
could you play
please make your way to the microphone
mr court
shall start
yep
okay
we all know that the algorithm for
projected housing figures is wrong
but what is tdc doing to press further
on the identification of brownfield
sites for developments rather than
digging up our prime farmland
why are council officers not being
proactive in approaching owners of
brownfield sites and if it is not normal
practice
then will council officers look towards
changing this practice particularly in
light of the fact that we need our
farmland for food
growth production and not houses that we
do not need
[Applause]
thank you very much mr court i call upon
the leader to respond
thank you chair and thank you mr corp
for your question
the test for site allocations in
government guidance are available
suitably
are availability suitability and
achievability
which means that a landowner have to be
willing for the sites to be brought
forward they must be suitable in
planning terms across a range of matters
and be capable of delivery within the
plan period
the call for sites is only one part of
the process of identifying land for
residential and other developments
another part of the process is to carry
out desk and site surveys to identify
other sites including brownfield sites
that meet the site allocation criteria
above in cases where sites meet the
criteria above the landowners are
contacted to see what their intentions
are for the sites in question
this approach has been standardized for
many years
such work was carried out for the
adopted plan and is being undertaken at
the moment to inform the local plan
update
and i can assure you that i actually
spent sunday afternoon looking at our
brownfield site
list and
i will be reviewing it regularly as i do
with the planning
so that we can identify if anything is
actually
um going to be suitable uh
for the overall criteria that is needed
to be met so i appreciate your question
and hopefully that is an answer for you
thank you very much councillor ashby
agenda item 6b question number two from
a member of the public
also regarding the identification of
brownfield sites for housing
developments
i'm pleased to welcome miss brown to the
meeting could you please make your way
to the microphone miss brown
good evening um since the beginning of
the war in eu ukraine people are
becoming increasingly anxious about the
current and future food security because
of that region's importance in the
global supply of grains such as wheat
allowing the development of prime
productive farmland in vanit that also
grows wheat will decrease our ability to
grow food in this country adding to the
reliance on food imports we already
import 40 to 50 percent of our food in
light of this and the government's
emphasis on using brownfield for
development instead of greenfields can
you please tell me are you required to
actively search for brownfield sites and
if you are what are you doing to fulfill
this requirement
thank you very much indeed miss brown i
call upon the leader counselor ashby
again you can elaborate here on this one
thank you chair and thank you for your
question um as it is obviously very
similar to the previous question um
i will reiterate again the um
the
test for the sites is the availability
suitability ability and achievability
i do appreciate that um obviously the
ukraine well and russia at that point
are regarded as the breadbasket of
europe
and i think the situation out there is
is very alarming
um part of the process of identifying
land for residential and other
development is to carry out the desktop
service as i previously said
and
it should be noted there is not
currently and i will stress currently
an absolute protection for agricultural
land in the government guidance the
national planning policy framework says
where significant land for agricultural
land is demonstrated to be necessary
areas of poor equality should be
preferred to those of higher quality
but maybe with the war and maybe the
pressure that
we can put on the government then there
will be serious reconsideration
regarding the use of our agricultural
land so you can rest assured that
this council
will be
asking the government to constantly ask
the government to reconsider whether or
not they need to adjust their policy
their framework so um that's basically
the situation at the moment but your
your question is acknowledged and
understood thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed councillor
ashby
uh i have a question number three from a
member of the public regarding the
maintenance of public toilets uh from a
mr rain white who may not be here mr
wainwright are you here this evening
mr rainwright does not appear to be here
mr wainwright will get a written answer
to his question
so you're off the hook counselor cop
agenda item seven questions from members
of the council
now this evening i have seven questions
have been received from members of the
council please note that the time
allowed for consideration of questions
from members shall not exceed 30 minutes
i ask members to be succinct as possible
uh fo gender item 7a question number
from one from a member regarding the
future of thanet heritage theaters i
call upon councillor gregory
thank you chair
many of senate's heritage of theater
venues have in the past attracted large
audiences and are either closed now
derelict due to lack of routine
maintenance or are imminent to shut
possibly lost to thanet and its visiting
community forever
what plans does tdc have for westcliff
concert hall in ramsgate the granville
theatre in ramsgate the theatre royal
mar gate and the winter gardens margate
for them to be restored to their former
glory
thank you councillor gregory and council
pugh you're on the hook instead
i am chair thank you and i apologize to
anyone that's disappointed that it's
going to be me um but it is thank you
councillor gregory uh for your question
i have the following uh to share the
granville theater on victoria parade
ramsgate was built in the 1940s
originally as a theater with a cinema
screen added later the theater is owned
by the council but it's been managed by
leaseholders since 1998. the building
was leased to granville theater limited
in 2007 but that arrangement came to an
end in november 2020 when the lease was
surrendered the building has been closed
since the start of the national coved 19
lot down in 2020.
the building was last surveyed in 2017
and this highlighted an extensive list
of necessary maintenance with a total
cost estimated at 152 000 pounds
in addition to this the roof is in a
particularly poor condition and repairs
are estimated to cost around 250 000
pounds
in july 2021
uh members of thanic district council's
cabinet agreed to transfer the granville
theatre into the hands of a community
organization if a viable beard was put
forward in october 2021 we invited
community groups to express their
interest in
poor's
uh interested in bidding for the
freehold of the building and the right
to continue to operate
commercial property agents will shortly
be offering the building on the open
market inviting proposals that reflect
the status condition and future use of
the property eligible community groups
including the kent film foundation will
have the opportunity to bid alongside
commercial organizations
in relation to the
west
west cliff hall in
ramsgate it is in private ownership and
therefore
not a matter of tdc that we can comment
on beyond saying that we are sharing a
view that we very much want to see it
developed positively the theater role
forms part of the margate town deal and
within the town deal scaling creative
production and skills intervention
there is a two million pound allocation
for the fiat project the town investment
plan states that this will be used uh to
improve the theatre role and the
surrounding environment to create a new
hub for theatrical production
in relation to the winter gardens
there's a margaret town deal board which
is our central government for revenue
funding to support the margaret winter
gardens in the development of a
long-term plan
as a result there is now 300 000 pounds
of revenue funding allocated for the
winter gardens project
the funding will enable a piece of work
which will provide a clear vision and
detailed uh project delivery plan for
the winter gardens future including how
it can operate in tandem with the other
leisure venues and key heritage assets
in margate featured in the town
investment plan dreamland and the
theater role
thank you very much councillor pugh
councillor gregory do you have a
supplementary
thank you and i just want to know why
these places aren't routinely maintained
they seem to get into a state before
anything's done
thank you councillor gregory thank you
councillor pugh for that
sorry yes i back to you counselor pugh
for that
it's all right chair thank you i
appreciate it i've already spoken too
much but i've got other questions to
answer later as well so everyone have to
get used to it um thank you council
gregory i completely understand uh your
concern of course we as a council it's
incredibly important it's our priority
uh to see many of these wonderful assets
restored back to their former glory um
which i'm sure you'll wear as a council
and every one pound of council tax of
residents pay we only receive 12 pence
services are very tight at the moment
so unfortunately some things do slip
but what i would say is that it's not
always should shouldn't always be the
priority of the council to maintain
these buildings and keep them going if
there are community groups that have the
passion and flair and the funding
available
to bring them back to even better than
their former glory
thank you very much indeed councillor
pugh
gender item 6b question number two from
a member regarding the allocation of a
traveler's site i call upon councillor
rolfe
thank you leader um thank you
my question is for a leader a traveler's
issue has been ongoing for some time the
working party has been set up for nearly
two years to allocate a place for them
can they lead the real show as we will
hear the result very soon thank you
thank you councillor roth i call upon
the leader to respond
thank you chair and thank you councillor
for your question
it was decided that suitable sites for
gypsy and traveller accommodation should
be identified through the local plan
process
the site search and allocation process
for the local planned update is being
undertaken at the moment
the test for site allocations are
availability
suitability and achievability which
means that land owners have to be
willing for their sites to be brought
forward
they must be suitable in planning terms
across a wide range rock player wide
range of matters and be capable of
delivery within the plan period
no sites sadly have been proposed to the
council specifically for consideration
as gypsy and traveller sites which means
that the site search work has to be
extended
thank you very much indeed councillor
ashby council ralph do you have a
supplementary
yeah yes i got a supplementary question
is regarding their
families already are in ramsgate port
these families their kids are going to
local schools some of them they're
registered with gps
and also they help in our local
community especially with food bank
and council spending money
taking them to court to move them from
there and by moving from the port and
spending taxpayers money or keep
removing them we're just moving from
there to somewhere else and then they
have to take them to court again to move
them from there
can we just leave them where they are
and can the leader tell us
we would be happy to meet up with
interesting party
and find a right solution for these
people thank you
thank you councillor roof councillor
ashby
thank you um
chair and thank you councillor off um
the way that i can help the families the
travelling um fraternity and the gypsy
fraternity is to actually find a
long-term solution for this council to
provide suitable
sites for them to come
and live safely and
and for their children to attend schools
etc i can't comment on on the port
situation because at the moment there
are various processes which are being
handled by the senior officers of this
council of which i cannot get involved
in
but i can confirm
and i want to reiterate that
it is my priority in the time that i
have remaining to try and find a
solution to the problem of the of us as
a council not having a suitable stopping
and permanent site for
for the travelers and the gypsies so i
can confirm
even this is the latest uh very hot news
because we only had the meeting this
afternoon but councillor joe baker and
myself met with senior officers of the
council to discuss the recent department
of leveling up housing and community i
wish they wouldn't have such a long
title the 10 million capital fund to
support local authorities in building
new transit and permanent travellers
sites
i'm very hopeful that a bid will be
submitted by the 13th of june 2020
deadline
[Applause]
and if it is successful which i very
much hope that it is it will be
certainly assist us in providing a
solution for this matter for on a long
term sustainable future thank you
well well done
thank you very much indeed leader
councillor ashby
gender item 7c question number three
from a member regarding the future of
the pieryard toilet a serious issue but
rather musically put i call upon
councillor everett
thank you chair
can cancel the cup as the cabinet member
flush away rumors that the future of the
pr toilets which provide the main public
conveniences for ramsgate main sands is
in doubt
is this conservative administration
which has no concern no ramsgate
councillors on its front bench
considering pulling the chain on them
there it was there's the punchline i
called upon councillor cup to respond
thank you chair and thank you councillor
everett it's it's uh it's often as if
there's a broken record on here because
it's worrying that the leader of the
labour group still cannot seem to
realize that the conservative cabinet is
here to work for the whole of thanet not
just the awards that we are counsellors
for and clearly it has escaped
councillor everett's attention that his
own shadow cabinet doesn't represent the
whole of than it but as a cabinet member
working for the whole of thanet i will
of course answer the main
trucks of his question a decision on the
future of the toilets across the whole
district needs to be taken and we are
developing a strategy to deal with the
issue that covers a range of options and
any proposal will go to the cabinet for
decision thank you chair
thank you very much indeed councillor
cup i see some
cuts and thrust developing uh councillor
do you have a supplementary question
well of course the shadow cabinet isn't
making decisions about areas that he
doesn't represent can the council of cup
tell us then um if he was a member of
the public who was caught short in
ramsgate in the future who found that
the council had closed the pr toilets
the council had closed the cavendish
street toilets the council had closed
the kingdoms to six park toilets and the
council had closed the ramsgate cemetery
toilets what they ought to do
thank you councillor everett back to you
councillor cup
unfortunately i can't
answer to fantasies so i don't know
thank you
all right
agenda item 7d question number four from
a member regarding the future of the
grandfather ramsgate i call upon
councillor austin
thank you chair a bit of a theme i'm
afraid councillor pugh
in the light of the confusion and upset
over the future of ramsgate granville
theater i'd be grateful if you could
clarify the current situation the
process going forward and i know you've
done some of this um in your helpful
responses to residents who've expressed
concern understandably you've stressed
our need to ensure best value
sadly best value in ramsgate to date has
consistently been interpreted as sail to
the highest bidder
leaving important buildings like west
cliff hall the west cliff under cafe and
18 albert street derelict generating
significant negative ongoing value for
our residents and for our visitor
economy we're delighted to see the
granville featured as a key attraction
in our regeneration team's recently
published landscape future plan
could you please outline the process
we'll follow for this important asset
for now on and explain what we're doing
to ensure the granville elements of the
ramsgate future plan can still be
delivered thank you
thank you councillor austin councillor
pugh
thank you chair and thank you council
austin
for your question um as i have covered
some of this already i won't go over it
all again but i'm more than happy to
provide you with a full copy of the
response you've got it for your records
in july 2021 members of the district
council's cabinet agreed to transfer the
granville theatre into the hands of a
community organization if a viable bid
was put forward in october 2021 we
invited community groups to express
their interest in bidding for the
freehold of the building and the right
to continue to operate it we received a
submission from kennedy film foundation
which was considered by a panel of
officers from across the council the
submission was scored in strict
accordance with the community asset
transfer policy as a council we have a
duty to our residents to make sure that
any community group that wants to take
on a public building can provide the
evidence that it has the skills and
experience to do so and that the project
has a long-term long-term future that
will benefit the wider community
unfortunately the kff submission did not
provide adequate designs or costings for
the refurbishment of the building and
lacked proof of funding and a realistic
business plan
that doesn't mean that they can't now
bid under the community rights bid which
i believe they are doing so
commercial property agents will shortly
be offering the building on the open
market inviting proposals that reflect
the status condition and future use of
the property eligible community groups
including the kent film foundation will
have the opportunity to bid alongside
commercial organizations
thank you council pugh uh i call upon uh
council austin do you have a
supplementary council austin i do thank
you chair uh thank you council pugh what
i'm concerned about obviously is is what
is going to happen with this building in
the future and obviously that's what
ramsgate residents are concerned about
you say proposals that reflect the
status condition and future use
of the building
is cabinet committed to ensuring that
the future use of this building is as an
entertainment venue as featured in the
ramsgate future plan rather than it
going to developers like so many other
buildings have in ramsgate thank you
thank you costa council austin back to
you councillor pugh
thank you chair and thank you council
austin for your supplementary what i
would say is that we as a cabinet we're
in we're committed to ensure that the
best possible future for the granville
theatre as a building uh continues to
and that's what it has whether that be
you in the hands of a community group or
within a private ownership through the
auction or whatever following the
process
remains to be seen but our priority is
to ensure that the best possible use of
the building and the best utilization of
the building is what happens
thank you very much indeed councillor
pugh
agenda item 7e question number five from
a member regarding disabled parking base
now this question is from council
whitehead who is not here this evening
therefore she will get an answer in
writing
agenda item 7f question number six from
a member regarding affordable housing
requirements for housing developments
again i this is from councillor farence
who again is not here this evening she
too will receive a question early answer
in writing
agenda item 7g question number seven
from a member regarding the council's
response to public concern about the
future of the granville theatre ramsgate
i call upon councillor christendom
councillor crittenden
thank you yes you're on the stage again
um
has the leader noted the extent of
concern in ramsgate and beyond about the
future
would you put your microphone on
it is
like i'm down here
has the leader noted the extent of
concern in ramsgate and beyond about the
future of the granville theatre
what steps is she taking to address this
concern and reassure the public that her
administration is listening to what
local people obviously want thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed counselor
chris i'm sorry to interrupt you it's
just i couldn't hear you very well um
but councillor pewt i think you heard
that
over to you
thank you chen thank you councillor
criticism i apologize you haven't got
the leader you've got me um but i will i
will try and do my best we are almost
matching to be fair so it's almost the
same you look alike um
oh i love it um the leader in cabinet
have very much listened to the views of
local people regarding the granville
theatre which is why in july 2021 the
cabinet agreed to transfer the grand
theatre into the hands of a community
organization
um if a viable bid was put forward of
course i'm not going to now uh council
critic go over
the same response that i've provided i'm
more than happy to provide you with a
full copy of this as well
but everything is within strict
accordance with our community asset
transfer policy
of course again we have a duty to
residents to make sure that any
community group that wants to take on
the public building can provide the
evidence that it has
the skills and experience to do so and
that the the project has a long-term
future that will benefit the community
the granville theatre is a location that
holds fond memories for many local
people and i recognize that the cabinet
recognises that and i understand the
strength of feeling and the concern from
residents about its future
but it is incredibly and it's really
encouraging to see the amount of
positive local support for its
redevelopment
we're committed to securing the positive
future for the building whatever that
may be and we hope that it will well and
it will benefit the local community for
generations to come and i think that's
an incredibly important thing uh to say
not just council christian but to all
councillors here you know there are
difficult decisions that need to be made
this council owns a lot of assets um and
it's important that we don't just sit on
the assets and do nothing and if a
community a community group or a private
individual can do better with
assets that the council owns um then i'm
all for us making that reality as we
have done before whether it has been a
success or not um i always think it's
something that we should explore
thank you councillor pugh country
christendom do you have a supplementary
uh yes please um
will the leader confirm that she will
deliver the granville to the benefit of
the local community and i hear what you
said
um enable in order to reassure the
residents it will not end up as flats or
a supermarket which is their greatest
concern or yet another failed derelict
site which is what
comes back to other questions thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed council of
crittenden and now you address that to
the leader but i'm got a feeling
councillor pugh might be responding
thank you chair you're right you know
i'm happy to step in for the leader and
take the hit it's fine um
council christian thank you for your
supplementary and i do appreciate that
um i think it's important to say that
within any transfer of an asset such as
the granville whether it be to a
community group or to a private
individual there's certain things within
the sale that we can stipulate now if
that means that there's a
stipulation that it won't can't be used
for residential development or something
like that i'm more than happy to commit
now that they'll that will do that i
don't think that's necessarily an issue
um
you know i think it's a difficult
situation but what i would say is that
there are some assets going way back you
know some iconic buildings in ramsgate
that are now not what they were i think
the former iceland used to be a big
cinema years ago you know it's not
anymore but it's now got a use for the
community that's completely different um
i'd be interested to see a supermarket
try and turn the granville into a tescos
or waitrose but
um
you know that remains to be seen um but
i do hear what you're saying and of
course we're committed to try and bring
the best outcome for the granville for
the wider community
thank you very much indeed councillor
pew
gender item eight motions on notice no
motions unnoticed have been received in
accordance with council procedure rule
three so i therefore move on to agenda
item nine the leaders report i therefore
call upon the leader councillor ashby to
present her report
thank you chair
firstly i would like us all to take a
moment to reflect on the situation in
ukraine
and the pain and suffering one power
crazed man can cause to so many men
women and children
i think we must all think about this
when we're fighting our local battles
there is
a big
there is a big battle going on somewhere
that is outside of our control but we
must all remember how things can
escalate out of control
it is of enormous concern and we stand
in solidarity with the ukrainian people
here in sanet we are committed to
playing our part in the national effort
to welcome and support refugee families
the government has announced that local
authorities will be provided with
funding to deliver the wrap-around
support needed by refugees coming into
the uk but at this stage it is unknown
when or how many ukrainians might be
arriving in planet
in the meantime we are working with our
partners in the kent resilience forum
and government to identify how support
can be provided to include accommodation
safeguarding checks
translation services access to health
services and education
the final ramsgate heritage action zone
sea front place making is reaching the
end of its fifth and final year its
focus on ramsgate seafront from west to
east cliffs and along the promenades
will explore the past present and future
recording what ramsgate seafront means
to the local community today and for
time to come
the establishment of the margate
creative land trust received the good
news from the government that the plan
has now been approved
the aim of the trust is support is to
support and grow creative practices
enabling local people to have
opportunities to participate in the arts
trustees are being sought to fill the
roles to help provide ongoing strategic
direction and critical challenge
jackie bakers in ramsgate saw our first
ever community tree planting day the
event was part of the queen's green
canopy project and over 40 residents a
tan attended to plant a tree
with cabinet member council george cupp
deputy lieutenant clive stevens
councillor pat moore and as deputy as
deputy leader of ramsgate along with
numerous other councillors
our open spaces team also planted seven
larger trees to add to the 35 trees
already planted by the community
earlier in the month councilor bob
bayford cabinet member for climate
change attended a visit by lord devon
and the government and the government's
climate change committee to king jules v
park in garland
this was part of the national tour to
see first hand what different parts of
the country are doing to achieve
ambitious climate ambitious climate
goals and we were delighted that lord
devon chose to visit us here in sanex
speaking at a meeting in mainstream
later that day
where i was in attendance lord devon
said how impressed he was
at how the various parties have come
together to make the suds project such a
success
various
digital technology projects have been
launched showing thanet leading the way
forward on resident and business
communications
there is the green tourism toolkit a new
toolkit to support local businesses with
ideas to help them to become more
environmentally friendly and showcase
the district as a responsible tourism
destination
then there is the online waste portal a
new digital waste portal for residents
to access details of all their waste and
recycling services online
it will provide real-time information
about bin collections allow residents to
report any issues via the portal without
needing to complete a form
bing collection calendars and
subscription signs up to the council's
garden greenway services
finally the
other portal to speak of is the open
portal which is a new and secure online
portal enabling residents and businesses
to see and manage their council tax and
business rates accounts housing benefit
claims payment history notification
letters and much more all in one place
it will enable viewing of up-to-date
account information checking of your
balances review payments apply for a
single person's discount update contact
details report a change of address
switch to paperless billing and set up a
direct debit unfortunately unlike the
energy companies we can't give a
discount for a paperless billing
the fourth edition of our action against
litter newsletter was published online
giving details of the seventh annual
great british spring clean three-day
district-wide spring clean event which
takes place during the first week of
april
soon
coming up i believe next week
tdc councillors and staff will be taking
part along with our district-wide
all-year-round volunteer litter-picking
army which we are most grateful for all
their efforts that they do continuously
included in the news was a reminder of
the great work of plastic free
broadstairs the palm bay primary school
and enterprise learning alliance pupils
who were awarded certificates for
learning
for litter-picking activities
tdc has now awarded 60 certificates to
pupils across thanex
ahead of next year's elections we are
hosting a become a councillor event to
encourage people living and working in
sanet to find out more about the
district councillor role
it is important that our groups within
the council chamber reflect the
community it serves and it is important
to encourage people from across spanish
diverse communities to come forward and
to help make a difference to people's
lives
finally residents in margate will have
received a leaflet through the door
about margate's bid to become a town
council
unlike other towns
unlike other fanuc towns margae is a
charter town and the trustees have
launched a bid for a town council
people registered to vote in the seven
margate wards are eligible to sign a
supporting petition and should enough
signatures be reached it will trigger a
community governance review by the
council thank you for your time
listening
thank you very much indeed leader i call
upon the counselor everett to comment on
or ask questions in relation to the
leaders report council everett thank you
chair uh i'd like to thank the leader
for a report and i'm sure that we all
share the same concern about what is
happening in ukraine
i know that there are residents in
thanoid who are ready and willing to
house refugees and i hope the
bureaucracy won't get in the way of
their generosity and i'm also sure that
those who do come will contribute to our
community as have those who came before
them
i am of course in full support of the
become a councillor initiative and i'm
delighted as i'm sure the leader is that
we in the labour party were able to help
one local resident become a councillor
here last week
welcome councilman exe
i note that the press release highlights
a need for councillors from thanks
eastern european and roma communities
but there are of course many groups that
are underrepresented in this council and
some that are well represented including
i'm pleased to say child and athletic
supporters
but that may not be the top priority for
residents
seriously we need to think how we
motivate people from all sections of the
community to become councillors
regardless of party or football
allegiance as i said in paying tribute
to the late mary king last month we
needed more councillors from relatively
deprived backgrounds to make sure their
voice is heard in this chamber and i
don't know but i wonder how many current
members live in social housing for
example
we also need more younger people
i don't think we encourage either with a
basic allowance of
4570 pounds
parents of young children often working
hard to keep their heads above water
usually can't afford the time it takes
to do the job of being a counselor
properly if it prevents them earning
and of course there are issues of
affordability for the council and of
course it is about public service but it
often seems to me that some of us are
selective in their interpretation of the
role of the market perhaps fewer
councillors would help us in that
respect
councillor whitehead isn't able to be
here tonight because she's recovering
from kovid but i know she would make the
point that april is autism acceptance
month and that diversity takes many
forms
what we can all do to encourage new
people to come forward is to show that
being a councillor matters that what we
do makes a difference and be visible in
our wards not just on social media or
even mainstream media and also be honest
about the difficult decisions the
council has to make whoever is in
control otherwise we just feed cynicism
i welcome the success of the milegate
creative land trust the community tree
planting initiative at jackie bakers and
the forthcoming litter picking events
although i know that this work is
already well underway in ramsgate
many hands late make light work is the
claim but i think those involved might
dispute that because i know it can be
very hard work
either way it's a real challenge to
maintain our streets and open spaces in
this respect throughout the year and we
must continue to challenge the culture
that says it's okay to leave litter in
the first place especially when most of
it isn't biodegradable
of course with our visitor economy it's
not just residents who are responsible
as far as the new digital services are
concerned anything which makes waste
collection more efficient for residents
has my support but mistakes do
inevitably occur and i think the real
test is on the council's ability to
whether the council's ability to respond
when notified of them actually improves
obviously if the service is run on a
tight budget the capacity to recover
errors is going to be limited but being
told you've got to wait a week or a
fortnight just adds to the initial
frustration
finally on the subject of margate town
council in some ways it's hardly my
business
but i do commend to the good people of
margate the example of ramsgate town
council and i know that the leader was
at the ramsgate town meeting last night
to hear how positively rtc is regarded
by those residents present
as the late peter campbell would
regularly remind us it is in ramsgate
and broadstairs and the other parishes
interest for there to be a margate town
council because without it residents
elsewhere will continue to be taxed
twice
paying for margate to receive some
services through tdc as well as for
those in their own area through the
parish precept
but margate will also benefit from more
autonomy and opportunity to deliver
hyper local initiatives so i do hope the
local people will support it but of
course if margate wants a town council
as good as ram gate rams gates will have
to give it a labor majority too
thank you very much any councillor
everett uh councillor ashby you're not
going to dispute too much of that are
you
i thank councillor everett for his
response um
might struggle a little bit with your
last comment unless they change the
boundaries of course um which
is always on the cards um
thank you for your comments um
if i unless i missed it there wasn't
actually a question in there but um uh
we all we i like to think that we you
know we are thinking along the same
lines and agree with you that uh
we need to encourage young councillors
um quite proud that i've got
you know
three youngsters sitting here to my left
[Laughter]
[Applause]
when when bob first became a counsellor
yes he was very young but um no um on a
serious note it is a problem for for
young people to be a counselor and give
it a lot of time because they most of
them have full-time work and
we obviously try and adapt our working
ways around that but
the allowance is probably an issue um
it's
it's a very difficult one to um if i i
did have the cabinet did contemplate
very heavily this time whether or not to
put it up but unfortunately there just
wasn't enough left
in the budget to do that but a
conversation that we did have and um
with dem services or i had with dem
services was that we felt that we could
probably put a little bit away for the
next for the in the next budget year and
then if we did it the following year
then we could actually then result in uh
raising at least
the basic allowance i don't know whether
the chairs need to um
gain any ground on that but the trouble
is i think it's been year on year there
haven't been increases for a very very
long time and even if you just put it up
a little bit every year at least it
doesn't fall that far behind but
it is a problem so i thank you for your
response and
i look forward to
the new councillors coming in in may 23.
thank you very much indeed councillor
ashby we
all seem to be friends tonight out here
don't we
i call upon counselor reverend piper to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report
and there it is jeff
the opportunity to ruin the atmosphere
um
just a comment about if i may about the
uh
ramsgate town council on the subject of
allowances
ramsgate town council has managed in
recent months to actually pay itself
twice
the allowances allocated as war grants
and now also as allowances it is a
decision that's being challenged but it
is something that they've
managed to come up with under a labour
administration
could we have an explanation of how this
relates to the leaders report
yes i'm a afraid you'll write counsellor
um uh
councillor everett uh councillor piper
could you explain that uh i don't think
it does but very quickly if it does tell
us how it was the question of allowances
uh mr chairman uh a comment about
allowances a comment about the
efficiency of the ramsgate town council
county council
councilman
we're not here to talk about ramsgate
town council
unfortunately though it may be pressing
this evening we are here to talk fanuc
council business
so i will make that the end of that
sentence thank you chair
first of all then thank you leader for
your report and your comments about the
situation in ukraine
i wonder if we might have
a clear statement
regarding such things as gas and
electrical safety checks
and any other local authority
checks that need to be made in order for
householders to become sponsors
of those traveling from
the ukraine there is a lot of comment on
social media about these things and most
people seem to be finding that they've
using the government scheme and other
ngos
have come up with a sponsorship
agreement only then to fail on a
requirement of their local authority so
i wonder if it's possible
that we could have a clear statement
from the council not this evening
necessarily but a clear communication to
all members so we know how to
communicate that to the members of the
public
it was great fun to be involved
in the jackie baker's event although i
did spend most of the time coughing
it was a a very popular event it's being
well supported
around the island
can i just comment i haven't written in
about this to the open spaces ramsgate
tankouts are looking to plant a lot more
trees
the avenue that's been started on jackie
bakers is a good start perhaps we could
have a meeting a discussion about the
possibility of continuing that avenue
all the way around the edge of that
field
the online waste portal
i think it will be good in the end there
are the inevitable teething problems and
i'm quite sure they will be dealt with
but for
some of our residents in buxton road and
hybrid gardens for example to go six
weeks without
proper collections and then to have the
portal telling them they've been
collected when clearly they haven't it
is a real issue i wonder if you could
get the relevant team to have a look at
that please
the supporter councillor become a
councillor event we've been doing our
best to support that on social media
having invited several people to come i
hope it will be a successful evening and
thanks to the team for putting it on
that that concludes my attempt to ruin
the atmosphere mr chairman
no you haven't ruined the atmosphere at
all councillor piper i'm sure councillor
ashby is delighted to respond here
thank you chair
thank you councillor piper
yes uh unfortunately i can't comment on
the um
the
allowances on at ramsgate town council
but i did enjoy my visit last night and
i was um
suitably hosted even though there wasn't
any water he
counselor auburn did promise me a gin
and tonic but there wasn't even there
wasn't even a glass of water
[Laughter]
the household checks
when the
crisis first started i did i asked the
chief executive to set up a dedicated
page on our website which
she did organize along with the comms
team and there's lots of information on
there
so therefore as the chief executive here
listening i will ask if the comms can
actually
add the household check and that
procedures where um
where we where
households are taking in
refugees um what they need to do
regarding the checks so
i'm sure she can confirm that and it
will be added to our dedicated page that
is already there
um the continuation of the tree planting
um i will pass that to our climate
emergency cabinet member who i'm sure
will be more than happy to have the
conversation with you regarding that
um
and finally i the early teething
problems with uh with the new digital
hub i i would imagine that any system
when you're launching it and i
understand today all the energy websites
crashed because everybody was trying to
enter their meter readings for the last
day of
31st because they've been told that
that's what they need to do so the whole
of the energy uh websites uh crashed
today so um
i'm sure that there's some sympathy with
launching which
what is
quite a revolutionary technical hub for
for our waste collection service but of
course once the teething problems are
sorted out the data will allow us to
provide an even better service than
we're already providing so thank you for
your comments and uh i hope that the
answers are to your liking
thank you very much indeed councillor
ashby did i hear that right council
auburn the opposition
buying drinks for the leader
perhaps not uh councillor garner i turn
to you for questions in relation
yes of course yes dude
i i didn't have any money on me
oh it's levity tonight isn't it i call
upon counselor ghana to comment on or
ask questions in relation to the leaders
report counselor garner
thank you chair and thank you yeah i'm
sure i'm sure all of us share the legis
horror at the events which have unfolded
in ukraine over the last few weeks and
we welcome seeing the ukrainian flag
flying over our offices to demonstrate
our solidarity with the ukrainian people
in their fight
it's also been heartening to see the
large number of people across fanat
who've rallied to their cause and
collected large numbers of items to ship
out to poland to help in the relief
we welcome the focus of on the community
throughout the rest of the report we are
indeed fortunate to have engaged in
enthusiastic communities who want to
work with the council and it's important
we do all we can to listen to and work
with our residents as much as possible
the recent tree planting events across
the district have been heartening to see
we'd like to thank all officers who've
worked hard to make sure as many trees
as possible were planted in a number of
different locations and i'm sure those
members of the community who got
involved will be keen to watch their
trees grow and do their best to make
sure no harm comes to them
of course
while it's important to plant as many
trees as possible it's equally if not
more important to make sure we do all we
can to protect those trees we already
have
too few mature trees are protected and
too many of these are being filled
because they're seen to get in the way
of anything from new developments
to a view of the coastline
our priorities need to shift
those of us on the climate change
committee mentioned in the report
and chaired by councillor bob bayford
received a stark update this week from
our climate change officer on the latest
report from the intergovernmental panel
on climate change on the urgency of
climate action and the need for keeping
the 1.5
degrees limit alive
this isn't something we can put off and
i know
many officers are working hard to make
sure our action plan is kept on track
we're pleased to see the good work being
done in king george v park to help
reduce the surf the risk of surface
flooding
that area leading down from all saints
avenue and heartstown road has been a
flooding hotspot for a number of years
and i know a number of agencies
including kcc and southern water have
been working hard to improve the
situation
because they're going to need to
they're going to need to think extra
hard about the additional enhancements
that will be needed to alleviate the
likely flooding problems which are going
to be caused by the addition of a few
thousand more houses within a mile or so
of that site in westgate and garland
if approved
it's good to hear about the tech digital
technology projects as it's important
for us to make more information readily
available to residents online
we do of course have a high percentage
of older residents some of whom are not
confident online
so we must not assume everyone will be
confident using these and make sure
we're also able
to present a friendly personal face to
residents at all times
of course whether it be online or in
person it's crucial that we always abide
by our commitment to be open and
transparent so people who pay their
council tax know what to expect and can
be confident they will get a straight
answer to a
question we welcome the beer councillor
event taking place on thursday april the
7th and encourage as many people as
possible who want to attend to do so
we need more people who want to actively
participate in local democracy to get
involved as that's the best way to
effect positive change across our
communities
and finally the great british spring
clean
this is another good example of how
members of the community have come
together to take action to clean up
their neighbourhood with the support of
council officers of both district and
town levels
there are still a number of litter picks
planned for the next few weeks
including tomorrow morning meeting in
the station car park on some peters park
road at 10 am
anyone else who wants to join us there
to keep our neighborhood clean would be
more than welcome thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
ghana uh i'm not sure identified a
question there but um council ashby do
you wish to respond
thank you chair
yes i
i agree
a tree is for life
it's the easy part is the planting and i
can assure people that that is the case
we do need to
look after these trees and
pass them on to the
next generation to look after and to
understand it so
we have to consider that when we're
planning any planting that we can
actually maintain them
for a long for a longer period
um
pleased to say uh i mean the george the
fifth um
suds project was was excellent and also
um the landscaping that has
come as a result of that um it did take
kcc quite a long time to to get their
act together on that because of the
covid lockdown et cetera et cetera but
it's actually looking quite stunning
there on that part now and it's a it's a
vast improvement to what it was even
before they they dug the big hole there
so it's actually
proof that you can actually come up with
a really good solution and then end up
with a really nice
uh design and
an open space for a community to go and
sit in
so um pleased to say that i sit on the
um
i think it's called the task force the
southern water task force
um we haven't had an awful lot of
meetings but um
thanit um
have um actually there are plans for two
more sud projects within the sunny area
um so
it's quite important that when i sit on
that to obviously push us forward for
any any plans that are coming through so
um and i thank you for for your other
comments and um i wish everybody luck
with that with early to pick in and but
it's not just
it's not just the one week is it it's
all 52 weeks of the year so i certainly
you know when i go out for a walk most
days i've always got a dustbin bag in my
in my hand which i i pick up and
try and restrain the dog from actually
taking off with a plastic bottle so
yes i know but um if we all if we all
pick up five a day
then we'll we'll get there so thank you
for your comments
thank you very much indeed leader
agenda item 10 the annual report of the
chair of the overview of scruckney uh
committee
now i call upon councillor reverend
piper
who's going to present the report
councillor piper a big moment thank
you i've tried really hard you know i
can't get these shorter reports than
than
my learning friend counselor bayfield
over there so you'll just have to put up
me rambling i'm afraid
um
there are a number of items that are in
the report i'm sure members are all
familiar with them the panel has been
very busy i need to thank the officers
who support us
and provide us with not just the
background information we need but with
the guidance to make sure that we're
reviewing things properly i'd like to
thank all the cabinet members who've
come and presented to the panel and some
very interesting topics
and as i think i've mentioned before
already we had a visit from the police
recently which was quite illuminating
but we've asked them to we're asking
them to come back and give us a little
bit more specific detail on the subject
of modern slavery
um
there is a danger i think
uh
members and and i i just offer this as a
kind of course retail it's great for us
to be engaging with the public it's
great for us to be involving the public
in what's going on but sometimes it
would appear that that engagement is
some it comes across as somewhat
adversarial as if it's the public and
one or two of us against the council and
it doesn't really do us any good um
i wonder if i could encourage members
please to look at article six
of the district council's constitution
there are several pages within article
six which give you exactly and i include
myself in that gives us
exactly the role of the overview and
scrutiny panel exactly the decisions we
can call in and those we can't those
that are something to do with cabinet
and the political running of this
council and those that aren't
please contact me if there's anything
that you want us to have a look at
but i would encourage everyone to have a
look at article six of the constitution
it makes it very clear notably the
things we cannot look at it's not within
our purview
it sounds like i'm frightened of hard
work i'm not but it just saves the
public perhaps some members of the
public they get wound up on something
before they actually know the facts
behind the decision how it was taken why
it was taken and i believe it's our job
as councillors to try and prevent
that kind of thing
happening i i commend the report to you
uh members
and thank you very much mr chair
thank you uh reverend piper i think all
of that was very well received uh do
members have any comments
counselor bayford
no ok
thank you members agenda item 11 the
annual report of the chair of the
standard committee i call upon mr tucker
to present the report please can you
make your way to the microphone mr
tucker
good evening chair members and officers
of the council
i'm pleased to present my second annual
report which you've all seen i i've no
intention of reading it out i'm sure
you've already and you're capable of
understanding it and i'm happy to take
any questions i've got no other
observations to make except everything's
running smoothly thank you chair
thank you mr tucker do members have any
questions
and i don't see anyone indicating thank
you very much indeed mr tucker
agenda item 12 the annual report of the
chair of the governance and audit
committee i call upon councillor boyd to
present the report councillor boyd
thank you chair
i'm not used to speaking at full council
so bear with me
um this report provides an overview of
the government's nordic committee's
activity during the municipal year
2021-22
i'm pleased to report that the committee
continues to discharge its
responsibilities to provide independent
assurance of the adequacy of the
council's risk management framework and
the associated control environment and
provides robust scrutiny and challenge
of the authority's financial performance
as outlined in the body of this report
the committee has been actively engaged
with both internal and external audit
and i would like to thank all members
who have served on the committee during
2021
my thanks goes to the council offices
who have supported me in my role as
chair and in the work of the committee
to assist the committee in improving
their understanding of the council's
financial accounts and discharge its
responsibility for approving them a
novel subgroup was established with the
remit of undertaking a detailed review
of the 2021 to 22 accounts i would like
to thank the members who fully engaged
with the
with and participated in the work
subgroup and the officers for their
support
this has been a difficult year with the
continuation of the pandemic and
restrictions on meeting in person
however the committee and all committees
have overcome the challenges by
embracing virtual meetings when
necessary and meeting in person in
different venues
the council has also faced challenges
this year of receiving the statutory
recommendations made by grant thornton
under section 24 of the local audit and
accountability act 2014 work to address
those recommendations is ongoing but i
am pleased that the council has accepted
the recommendation and members of and
officers are cooperating fully with the
work of the independent monitoring
officer mr quentin baker
that's it
thank you very much indeed councillor
boyd well i thought you did very well
[Applause]
do members have any comments
and there are no comments thank you
gender item 13 recommendations from uh
standard committee questions
uh
oh yeah yes
now from i move that the recommendations
are set out in the report be adopted
with the vice chair please second
second that chair do members agree
i have a counselor everett
thank you chair i hope we can vote on
these two proposals separately um i have
no problem with the change to procedural
14.6 i do have a problem with the
proposal for 14.8 not least because it
seems to me the rule would then contain
a contradiction
um i have to say that i'm a bit
suspicious of any attempt to further
limit the opportunity of members to
challenge the executive
i think we should expect our cabinet
members to have a reasonable grasp of
their portfolios and to be able to
respond to high level supplementary
questions
regardless of that they have all the
power
it's the question is you get challenged
by the chair it's not the cabinet member
making the answer uh
members are not allowed to answer back
so i don't think that the balance of
pound is tipping any further in favor of
the executive and i have sat on both
sides so i do appreciate the situation
from both sides
if questions are too technical or
detailed council will not expect an
immediate response and if they're out of
order it's already the role of the chair
to intervene
but in this case the proposal doesn't
even make sense
the original amendment to the rule on
supplementary questions that went to
constitutional review working group was
to add
the chairman will be robust in refusing
to allow questions which do not arise
directly out of the original question or
reply the chairman's view on the issue
will be final
now i don't see a problem with that
except for the lapse into gendered
language which we previously said we
wouldn't do
however based on what was agreed at
constitutional review working party and
standards it would now read
the supplemental question must arise
must arise directly out of the original
question or
the reply
the question must be a question and not
a statement and arise directly out of
the response
so the rule would say firstly they can
arise solely from the original question
and then subsequently that it must arise
out of the response
frankly this is nonsense
i'm therefore moving an amendment
and the amendment is to delete the last
seven words of the proposal
and end the addition to the rule at the
word statement
it's entirely appropriate that a
supplementary question follows on from
the original question otherwise the
cabinet member could close down an issue
by giving a completely irrelevant
response and that cannot be right
on both grounds i asked the council to
support the amendment
thank you very much councillor well we
have an amendment tabled here are there
any other speakers at this point
yeah have i got a sector for that
council effort i have councillor roth
does anyone wish to take that up
council piper
thank you i'd like to say that i agree
with most of what
councilor everett has said when i raised
my hand earlier to
speak on on this matter
um
personally i i thought the supplementary
question would be better if it related
directly to the answer provided by
the cabinet member to whom the question
was asked rather than
relating to the original question it's
kind of we we might
we might just well change it and give
people the opportunity to ask two
questions because that's often what
happens we've all seen it
um if it relates to the answer and and
to go some way to perhaps
uh
offering some comfort to counsel everett
if any cabinet member
uh
or the leader decided to give a reply
that was completely nonsensical um and
didn't answer the original question then
the supplementary question simply calls
for a proper answer
so it's not necessarily that difficult
and i don't think it's about power
shifting but uh
i have to say i agree with most most of
what he says i think it would be clearer
if it was a
supplementary question in response to
the answer
thank you very much the council piper
would anyone else like to speak to uh
council office council bayford
yeah thank you chairman i think a lot of
this is kind of pain semantics and
what it seems to me is that council
needs to adopt the spirit of what's
meant by this rather than worry too much
about the words because we all stuck to
the spirit of it there'd be no problem
thank you very much councillor bayford
do i have any other speakers
we have an amendment councillor could
you remind us of the wording of your
amendment
uh yes chair so at the moment the
proposal is that the question must be a
question and not a statement comma and
arise directly out of the response and
the amendment is to delete and resp and
arise directly out of the response so we
would simply add the question must be a
question and not a statement
not yes thank you councillor everett
we'll have a vote now on that since
there are no other speakers on it those
in favor
and those against
and that is passed the amendment is
passed uh so we'll go back to the main
uh
we'll go back to the main
agenda item can we therefore have uh a
members agreement on the um two uh
procedural changes and with the
amendment
i think i'm doing this right
yes yeah so
those in favor
and those against
and any abstentions
and i think we've
got and five extensions and that is
passed
thank you very much indeed members
moving on to agenda item 14
recommendations from the standard
committee revision to delegations i move
that the recommendations set out in the
report be adopted with the vice chair
please second
a great year do members agree
agreed
agenda item 15 oh back to ramsgate
the ramsgate conservation area appraisal
i call upon the leader councillor ashby
thank you chair
i'm asking members and i'm seeking their
approval for the adoption of the
ramsgate conservation area character
appraisal and management plan document
containing locally specific information
of the area following the public
consultation in november december 2021 i
would also like to add that i think this
is an incredibly
fine document and
it will be a very good reference point
for anybody either visiting ramsgate or
offer for all of us across the district
of fanet thank you chair so i seek your
approval
thank you very much leader do you have a
second
councillor bayford
do members agree
thank you very much indeed agenda item
16 changes committees panels and boards
with members please refer to the
supplementary agenda number one
with members please note the existing
political balance on committees will
remain unchanged
thank you
nomination of members to serve on
committees um
group leaders uh do you have any
amendments you would like to advise uh
councillor ashby
thank you chair yes i would like to add
councillor shrub to planning as we were
one short on that i believe so
councillor shrub to add to planning and
add councillor lease to overview and
scrutiny
on governance and audit i will be taking
off councillor pugh and adding
councillor lee thank you
thank you councillor ashby councillor
everett
thank you chair i believe we have a
vacancy on licensing which counselor
curry has volunteered to fill thank you
councillor piper
no changes jeff
councillor ghana
no none here either
thank you very much indeed members
well
that concludes the business of space
this evening uh thank you all very much
indeed for braving the weather it's been
quite blurry up here well i can hear it
outside
good night everyone
you